blast your way to the nearest Amazon
Prime account because we have Sylvester
Stallone's greatest performance since
Judge Dredd
ler I am the law Samaritan is a
superhero action film with a big twist
that many won't see coming of course I
know I just had no idea so come with me
as we take a look at this new film and I
promise there will be more Stallone
quotes oh is this the problem I'm
supposed to be scared Samaritan is set
in the fictitious Granite City with
Atlanta Georgia the actual filming
location Samaritan tells the story of a
washed up superhero hiding from his past
this is Joe Smith and no you can't make
up a more generic name than that he's a
garbage man who holds an insanely
unhealthy amount of ice cream in his
fridge we'll get to why that is in a bit
Joe has a secret past one which if
discovered could turn his quiet life
upside down that's where we meet Joe's
neighbor Sam Cleary the same actor who
played ashtray from the HBO series
Euphoria and Stan in the latest season
of The Umbrella Academy it's no
coincidence that his name is Sam and the
movie is called Samaritan as Sam becomes
the pivotal character in helping Joe
overcome his past actually both
characters end up helping each other
each becoming Samaritans in their own
way but to really understand how this
film ends and its big twist we have to
set the stage on how Joe went from
beloved superhero to what I will
eventually become an old man alone
making YouTube videos in his basement
please take me back Stephanie Joe and
his twin brother grew up with superhuman
strength and the ability to heal
extremely fast it's never explained how
they got these Powers but that's besides
the point their powers so worried the
local townsfolk that they gathered like
they crazed mob from Beauty and the
Beast lock the kids in their home and
set it Ablaze killing their
non-superhero parents in the process
this is the event that turns the two
brothers against each other one of them
becomes Samaritan a righteous superhero
who uses his powers to fight for justice
while his twin Nemesis uses them for
Revenge to get back at those who have
wronged them in this way Nemesis becomes
a symbol for the downtrodden a symbol to
stand up against of Oppression even if
it means through violence Granite City
becomes the perfect backdrop for this
because of the city's unrest working
class folk either can't find work or are
terribly underpaid Sam's mother can
barely make ends meet with her job as a
nurse and even gets evicted for a brief
time when she can't pay the bills an
event which forces Sam to seek out
dangerous jobs including stealing copper
wire and getting involved with a local
gang leader named Cyrus Cyrus is a huge
believer in nemesis's cause for Cyrus
Samaritan was a superhero who propped up
the status quo and defended the rich
Elites to him Samaritan was just another
cop
protect the rich one the rest of us went
hungry but Nemesis was the guy fighting
for the common folk a guy ready to start
a revolution for the downtrodden to rise
up his obsession with Nemesis is what
Spurs him to break into the police
department's evidence locker and reclaim
his legendary Hammer a hammer forged
with all of nemesis's hate and
apparently the only weapon that can
damage him and his brother but what
happened to Samaritan and Nemesis where
are they in present-day Granite City if
you believe the official reports the two
battled it out at a power plant where a
giant explosion took both their lives
but as we'll find out that's not exactly
how it went down Sam is obsessed with
Samaritan believing along with local
Bookshop and Samaritan conspiracy
theorist Albert casler that Samaritan
still lives when Sam is saved by Joe
from a group of local Thugs and
Witnesses his strength and ability to
crush a knife with his bare hands he
knows that Joe is Samaritan the two form
an unlikely friendship and I'd like to
think that Joe who grew up without a
father sees a bit of himself in Sam who
also doesn't have a father he'll later
tell Sam how lucky he is for having a
mom that cares for him Joe lost both of
his parents even Joe's hobby fixing
broken things is a metaphor for his life
he believes people like the objects he
repairs deserve a second chance no
friction that helps me relax and focus
and I figure some of these old things
deserve a second chance Sam watches Joe
miraculously heal after being run over
by a car solidifying that Joe is
Samaritan but we also see how Joe's
Powers come with their own limitations
every time he takes a huge beating
whether it be from a car or gang members
pummeling him with lead his body
overheats if he doesn't cool down
quickly his heart will literally explode
this is why he has a fridge jam-packed
with ice cream it helps him cool down so
when Cyrus finds out that Samaritan is
still alive after Joe saves the life of
a young girl and is caught on camera
Cyrus uses Sam as bait to lure Samaritan
to the local power plant to finish what
Nemesis started I also think it's no
coincidence that Cyrus wants to quote
bring power back to the People by
literally turning off the power he's
acquired these blackout bombs which shut
down any and all Electronics which
you'll use in an attempt to get the city
to rise up against its oppressive ruling
class so Joe who was moments away from
leaving town after his identity was
discovered has a change of heart coming
back to save the kid he's developed an
unlikely friendship with he uses his
garbage truck to Ram into Cyrus's base
and makes quick work of most of his men
their bullets doing absolutely no damage
to his body but Cyrus has Samaritan's
only weakness nemesis's Hammer he's able
to get the upper hand on Joe but not
before we're hit with the film's big
twist Joe isn't Samaritan he's actually
Nemesis years ago when Samaritan and
Nemesis battled it out at the power
plant Samaritan had the opportunity to
finish Nemesis once and for all instead
choosing to spare his life just like Joe
gave these old electronics a second
chance so too did Samaritan to Nemesis a
chance for him to become better
unfortunately Samaritan falls through
the roof of the power plant and despite
nemesis's best efforts to save him he
plummets to his death in this moment
Nemesis decides to throw both Mass Into
the Fire and live a life of solitude he
has lost everyone close to him by Saving
Sam from the clutches of Cyrus it gives
Joe a path to Redemption and proves that
Joe can change you can fix that
you can change everybody can change he
doesn't have to be the villain anymore
in the film's climax Joe defeats Cyrus
and Sam is interviewed by reporters he
could have told them the truth that
Nemesis still lives but instead tells
him that Samaritan lives and saved his
life thus completing Joe's Journey from
villain to Hero Joe is seen hiding in
the crowd hinting that he'll be heading
back into a life of solitude I mean he
could have come out and had the crowd
praise him for his heroic efforts as
Samaritan but that's just not who Joe is
so while Sam may have gotten more screen
time than Joe in this movie our
protagonist is actually Joe he's the
character that goes through the most
change throughout the film ultimately I
thought the film didn't bring much new
to the genre it took too long for Sam
and Joe's relationship to build and the
villain's goal should have had more
personal Stakes I actually thought it
would have been way more compelling if
Cyrus was nemesis's son and part of why
he wants to kill Samaritan is believing
Samaritan killed his father think how
crazy that twist would then be when
Cyrus finds out his dad has been alive
this whole time alas Hollywood doesn't
pay me the big bucks but I want to hear
your thoughts on Samaritan is this a
superhero dud or one you'd recommend let
me know in the comments below thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
glad you could drop in
thank you